welcome to exploring computing
today's video is virtual memory
so i've often remarked that many of my
students run too many programs at once
and it affects their computers
performance this is most noticeable when
they come to my office hours and
they're trying to get some homework done
but the computer is completely sluggish
and i look at their computer and they
have
huge amounts of programs all running
simultaneously
so one solution for this is
if their computer does allow them to
upgrade their memory they can add in
more memory and that that's actually a
great solution
assuming that their computer will allow
that upgrade and again many
many laptops will not and of course if
they can afford it
but one of the questions is why does the
computer let them open all these
programs
as long as the computer is able to run
these additional programs doesn't that
mean that there's enough memory
and the answer is no the computer is
using a system called virtual memory
that allows you to use more memory than
you actually have
and in many circumstances this can
actually be quite useful
but if abused you will end up with very
poor performance and so in this video
we're going to talk about
exactly what the virtual memory system
is why it's there
and when it works and when it doesn't
let's start off with the memory
hierarchy diagram so this diagram sort
of emphasizes that there's lots of
different types of memory
and that there's memory that's really
fast like
ram and in main memory and then there's
memory that's very slow
like say magnetic tape and somewhere in
the middle is our solid state drive and
our hard drive
and remember the faster the memory is to
access the more expensive it is per byte
so we can afford the slower types of
memory
much more easily because it's less
expensive
so generally we're going to have a mix
now
i also want to remind you that every
single one of these types of
memory stores bits and bytes here we've
got our
random access memory this is our memory
module and those diagrams below
are something called digital design
diagrams
there's something i really wanted to
teach students but
i never seem to quite have the time so
you know maybe we
move to online lectures more maybe i'll
make some
some online lectures on these probably
not this quarter though
and then we have our hard drive which
stores our
information using magnetic polarity and
then we have a cd drive
that's storing information using pits
and land
so depending on whether there's a pit in
a particular part of the
cd or dvd basically the transitions
between the pits and the lands represent
zeros and ones
all right so here's my computer here and
so what we're seeing here is
that square box on the right that's
supposed to represent our computer
memory
i'm going to assume i have a gigabyte of
memory and then i have a bunch of
applications i want to run
and each application takes a certain
amount of memory so back in the old days
the computer could run one program at
once so as long as i had enough
memory to run a particular program so
here we can see i
run in the web browser it needs 400k and
i've got a gigabyte so that fits in fine
or i want to run my media player
play some music and that takes 300k and
that fits in fine so that's all good
but of course we don't want to just run
one program at once we run around
wanted to run a bunch of programs and so
in addition to the programs that we're
running there's another program we need
to run
which is the system software operating
system so that's going to take some
space
and i'm going to fire up my web browser
and then i'm going to fire up my media
player
because i gotta have my tunes i'm going
to start my spreadsheet let's say i'm
working on a paper for
my economics class i'm going to fire up
my word processor and i'm starting to
run out of memory here
and then suppose one of my friends tries
to video conference with me
i'm out of memory so if we were only
able to use as much
memory as we actually have physically
available
in our actual computer memory chips i
would be out of luck
but fortunately we have a virtual memory
system so how does our virtual memory
system work
well in this example i've got a gigabyte
of actual
computer memory chips so i've got a
gigabyte of ram chips
but i've also got a hard drive or
you know in in most of your cases in a
solid state drive
and the bits on the solid state drive
are the bits on the hard drive are bits
just the same as the bits
in main memory so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take a section of that
solid state driver i'm going to take a
section of that hard drive
and i'm going to pretend that it's main
memory
but of course it's not that section of
will be able to store information
exactly the same as main memory does
and the operating system that system
software is going to
sort of it's going to sort of deceive
the programs into thinking that
it's actually in main memory when it's
actually on the hard drive or
on the solid state drive so they're just
bits
the same as the bits in main memory but
access to those bits is going to be much
slower
okay so let's see what happens here so
i've got
in this case i'm going to assume that i
have a gigabyte of
actual ram memory chips and then i've
got a gigabyte
on my hard disk which i'm pretending is
main memory
so now we're going to do the same thing
we did before so
i'm going to start my web browser my
media player
my spreadsheet my word processor and
then my friend's going to call with a
video conferencing system
and because i no longer have just a
gigabyte of
main memory i now have a gigabyte of
main memory and a gigabyte
on my hard disk pretending it's main
memory
the video conference call can go ahead
and start and i can throw in some other
things as well so
you know if i want to start with photo
editor
that fits as well okay so
ideally what happens is i have a bunch
of
applications that i'm actively using the
other applications are still open
and their documents are still open and
so from the computer standpoint
you know everything is running in memory
so previously we talked about how
you know when a program is not running
or when a document is closed
that information is just start on stored
in the hard disk and in order to
actually run
the instructions for that program need
to get copied into main memory and in
order to edit a particular document that
needs to get copied into main memory as
well
so what we could do with our virtual
memory is we can have the instructions
for those programs
open and the documents for them open and
it will look like
everything is running fine and what we'd
like to have happen is
as long as i have certain applications
i'm currently actively working on maybe
i've got some other applications that
are open
but i'm not directly interacting with it
most of the time our
virtual memory system is going to work
pretty well so suppose
i'm supposed to be working on my econ
paper but i'm actually browsing the web
playing my music and talking to my
friends on skype
now i've still got my word processor
running my spreadsheet running
and my photo editor running so those are
open
and any documents i'm currently working
on there they are there
i'm just not interacting with those
applications at all right now
so they're basically just sitting there
in the background but they are
open so i don't have to go to the hard
disk
and say you know file open those
documents are
actively open i'm just not interacting
with them
and then i realize it's starting to get
pretty late
and so i start working on
my paper and i start working my
spreadsheets and so what's going to
happen is
the computer's going to realize oh
you're actively using
these particular applications i need to
move
the contents the memory associated with
those applications from
this fake section of the hard disk which
is pretending it's main memory
i'm going to go ahead and swap those
with some other applications that maybe
you're not using
all right so what'll happen is the
system will take the sections
of real main memory and use them for the
applications that you're actively
working with and then it will use the
section of the hard disk which is
pretending it's main memory and use that
for
applications that maybe you're not
really actively using
and so this will work pretty well and so
you know you can have a lot of
applications open at once
and this will work now where this system
gets in trouble is
when you're constantly switching between
all your applications because in this
case there's no
single set of applications that you know
the active set of applications that
they can leave in main memory and
there's no inactive set that it can sort
of leave in the background
and so it's going to end up doing what's
called thrashing
and thrashing is where the system spends
all its time
moving pages back and forth pages is a
term for
these sections of memory that each of
these applications is using
cs106e students we'll be talking about
this in our
operating systems lecture and 105
students if you're interested
i will put those lectures up for you
guys after you learn how to program
after the first half of the quarter is
over anyway so this whole system is
going to
try and keep track of which sections you
need and which sections are kind of
inactive
but if you're actively trying to use
everything it will end up spending most
of its time moving
these sections to memory back and forth
instead of actually getting work done so
this is called trashing and
this is really bad so you will
know that you're having problems when
you have all these applications open
and you know the system seems to be
acting very sluggish
often what's happening is you don't have
enough real memory
and so it's using too much of
the sections on the disk and maybe it's
spending too much time swapping things
back and forth
so the best solution is if you can again
if your computer will allow you to
upgrade main memory
buying more main memory is actually
relatively cheap and it can give you a
huge performance boost
all right so that's our little
introduction to virtual memory
you